first we have sd carman telling
us about new proof for the kkl free boot
and telegram
theorems
okay thank you
[Music]
okay so this is joint rock with uh
subash hot guy killer
dorminter and my advisor melissa uh i
bought there the kcl because that's what
we can
see in this short talk um so let's start
with some basics
oops what they did um
okay so a boolean function over the
binary hypercube
so for every n we can think about the
n-dimensional binary hypercube
which is just a graph consistency of two
to the nodes
it one uh is n tuple of
zero zero and one bits
you can see as an example uh for three
the
edges are between every two knots that
differ in exactly one coordinate
and the boolean function is a function
of n input built and one output bit
we can think about it as just two
coloring of the end
of the binary hypercube and we have
two types of uh of edges
there are the uh the monochromatic edges
and the others
are the influential address there are
sensitive edges
we can call them centered and adjust
they are
they're just that are going between two
different values of the function
and we can straight our view to
one specific direction uh
say direction i and then we
can we ask how many sensitive edges we
have in this direction
the fraction of this address over all
the adjusting
in the direction i is the influence of
the variable i
this is just the probability of a random
uniformly random input
that flipping the ice bit changes the
value of the function we can sum up all
of them together
to get that and this is called the total
influence
this takes into account all the
sensitive edges in all over the cube
um in all direction and that's therefore
it's equals to
the number of sensitive edges in the
entire cube normalized to two to the n
minus one and that's why it's also
called
average sensitivity the total influence
and the influences are very important
properties of boolean functions
and basic questions in this area
related to it we can ask what can we say
about the structure of a function
if we know that the total influence is
small for example if we know that the
balanced boolean function as total
influence equals exactly one
we know that this is a dictatorship this
is not hard to see
and other basic classic results are the
kkl type results which we are talking
about
um so what we do is
we give a unified approach
a new group for this result
the kkl theorem which is which says that
for every balanced boolean function
either there exists a variable with
a large influence or the total influence
is large which say that
actually every ball and function can't
have both the total influence very small
and all the individual influence is
small
and the fried good quantitative say that
those functions with
small total influence essentially
depends on on
very few variables and targets
inequality
is a generalization of the kkk
and the in
the original proofs of all these three
theorems
there is a common uh key technique they
used
which is the um hypercontracting in
quality
and this inequality is considered a bit
my theory how it
how it works and it has some limitations
which are not in elaborate now we have
it sit in the long talk
uh what we do is uh to give a new proof
and the tools we use is uh random
restriction
with a very in a very certain way what
we try to do is to take the
in the random distinction to take the um
the fourier mass of the higher address
and put it to the lower levels
and then we get the total influence
small and the structure is
a bit simpler and
on top of this we apply the log software
of inequality
which uh in some sense replace
take the place of the hyper-contractive
inequality
so what we will see in the few minutes
we have
uh i'll try to cover the the
idea of the proof for the kkl uh without
all the an analysis we do to the log sub
of inequality
um but i i guess we'll we can
see something of it so let's start with
the random restriction
for this we need a bit about uh for your
analysis
a nice fact about functions over the
binary hypercube
even though that even those that go to
the aerials
every function has a unique
representation which called the fourier
representation
and looks like this this is the
summation over all subsets of variables
f at s times chi s of x
where chi s of x is the character
function
and what's important about it is that
this function
consider only the variables in the set s
and f s is the fourier coefficient of
the character s
this is the real number
and now we can define the degree of a
function we can see what is the
character
which has a non-zero the largest
character that has non-zero fourier
coefficient
and a nice fact about it is if we think
about the homogeneous function which is
a function that
the all the characters which are not of
the
of size d as the fourier coefficient
which is zero
then for these functions uh for this if
it's boolean function the total
influence equals d
the degree of the function
and now we can do random restriction on
this functions and
we have a function with n variables we
want to to
to have some subset of these variables
to stay alive
we choose a set of j of the variables to
stay alive with some probability mu
every
variable will be contained in j and
for the other variables we want to fix
them
so we choose some the assignment for the
other variables
randomly 0 is probability f and
one with probability half and this one
we get
a random function
it's each day the set of alive variables
and
assignment fixing for the other
variables define a function
which its values are the values of
a sub cube of the of f
and now we can ask some questions about
this random function for example
we we can know that for every if we
choose mu to be one over d
for every character subset of the
variables of size d
the number of alive variables that will
stay alive
is expectedly one
so now um i guess that i can do it in
one minute
and the proof idea of the
for the kkl we want to show that if
all the the individual instances are
smaller than the total influence is
large so we can think about homogeneous
function of degree d
and do one over the random restriction
then all the weight is on the green one
and then we know that every restricted
function is
actually a dictatorship that's mean that
each
a restriction said define uh
choose at some j to be the dictatorship
now we can partition all the uh
zeds in the in the cube according to
the dictatorship they chose so we
thought the
set aj is all the sets that chose each
day to be
their dictatorship and we can ask how
large is this
uh is this set so we can see
that if z is in aj then
xj is the dictatorship there
and therefore it's influential going in
direction
j will change the uh the function
the value of the function and for every
z that is not in x j
let's say in a l then x l
is the dictatorship there and therefore
x there is nothing
influential there and therefore the uh
the density of aj is exactly the
influence of the j's variable
um and now we assume that all the
influences are small
therefore also the um the density of aj
is small
so now we need to find uh some in other
place
in sensitive edges so look at an edge
that is in between two
two sets we can see that this edge is
going
from one dictatorship to other
dictatorship and therefore
this edge is is
sensitive so now we can
just count all of these edges and
we can see that there are many edges in
between the
uh the sets and here we use the
edges of our metallic inequality that we
can use
only here in this uh in this case it's
just the corollary of the log so bravine
quality and says that we have
many edges going from inside a small set
twice outside it we can sum up all of
them together
to get uh that we have large average
sensitivity which is a total influence
and uh this is the the the idea of the
proof
we need more analyze to because not
everything
looks just um so perfect
that we have exactly what we want
um so
we'll not do summary it's the same
about open questions we hope that this
new techniques
helps find more statements and
even prove known results
thank you thank you
okay i guess we have a time for uh maybe
a quick question
they will uh still uh sets up
do you have a question where can i see
it uh
you know feel free to to unmute yourself
and ask another question
so maybe one question that comes to mind
uh you mentioned all these famous
inequalities but one of them that i
noticed was missing is the fkn
inequality which is sort of like a
version of
freight good for uh level one
do you think that it can be proved using
these techniques or
if you can actually i use that
yeah um i don't know how to tell you
what to answer about it
so you used it as part of the kkl you
were saying or
no when when i i said that uh
that i have all the rate on the on the
first four-year level
and then the function is a dictatorship
it's not actually true
i need fk in it now let's see okay all
right
all right so maybe uh let's move on to
the next uh
speaker oh yeah i can't share my screen
unless uh i see stop showing your screen
i also remind you that we have a longer
version of the talks
and the conference website so
if you want to see more details you can
check it out
and feel free to to stay around for the
discussion and ask questions later
okay let's do can you share something
i'm trying
okay
all right so everyone can see my screen
yes
okay uh great great
so um
yeah for some reason zoom isn't letting
me share the window like i
planned yeah so it's forcing me to share
the whole screen
uh now it's probably too small
uh yeah i'm not sure what to do
you want to um stop the share and then
uh try starting it again
yeah sure
so
yeah it doesn't it doesn't seem to give
me an alternative except for sharing the
whole
screen
um maybe you can try again with the
whole screen and
i mean okay you can play with the side
of the window
okay
so i mean i can't i don't know what you
guys see so uh
so now it's again too big so if you can
make it a bit smaller then we can see
the entire
slide
just fill the first quadrant of your
screen
the uh you know with the window
yeah looks good now that's pretty good
okay all right sorry about this
uh so i guess uh shall we
should i start yeah
okay uh so this talk is about something
which we call the strongish planted
clique hypothesis and its consequences
and this is based on joint work with
possum monorangey and aviation
um so let's start so uh
the topic of this talk is the planted
clique problem
in which we have to distinguish between
the following two
graphs so either way the graph sampled
from g
and half which is the uniform
distribution over invertex graphs or
alternatively you can think of it as i
have n vertices and then i sample each
edge
to be in the graph independently with
probability half
my other distribution on graphs is i
will sample a graph from g n half
and then i'll choose a random subset of
k vertices and i'll put a click
on it and my goal is given a sample from
one of these two distributions to
decide which distribution it came from
with high probability
okay so because the size of the
largest clique in g in half concentrates
really well around two log n
there's a trivial algorithm running in
quasi-polynomial time basically you just
run brute force search over all cliques
of size slightly larger than two times
log n
in terms of efficient algorithms the
the size of the clique that we need in
the planted distribution
in order for the problem to be solved in
polynomial time is root n so this is
this is the best algorithm that we know
um it's a spectral algorithm due to
alone carbonyl rich and pseudo
and the planetary hypothesis states that
for any
clique size that's less than square root
of n asymptotically
uh the point of click problem is not
solvable in polynomial time
and this hypothesis has been used in
several um
hardness results so assuming that the
planetary hypothesis you can get
in approximately of densest k-subgraph
uh
hardness for finding the best nash
equilibrium
hardness of sparse pca and several other
average case problems
so this is a kind of popular hypnosis
uh and the main contribution of our work
is to introduce something that we call
the strongest splendid clique hypothesis
so this is the stronger version of the
planetary hypothesis which states that
as long as the size of the planted
clique
kappa is less than n to the point one or
there you can replace it
uh by any fixed constant less than half
the planetary problem is not solvable in
n to the little o
of log n time okay and and we call it
the strongest planetary hypothesis uh
in sort of a uh
homage to this to the strong exponential
time hypothesis except for
uh here we don't require that the
constant in front of the log
n is uh fixed to two so uh it's kind of
like a
like an exponential time hypothesis for
set but
for quantum clique
okay so so why would we make such a
hypothesis well
um it's supported by lower bounds
for uh large classes of algorithms so
for example there's a sum of squares
uh lower bound due to barack at all and
also
um similar lower bounds for statistical
query algorithms although
uh here you have to squint your eyes a
little bit in order to
accept these proof proof such lower
bounds
so in any case this rules out many
known algorithms and so if there's an
algorithm that beats
into the uh log band time it would need
to be
pretty different than any algorithm that
we currently know
okay so after introducing the strongest
planetary hypothesis we're able to
derive
several tight hardness results for other
problems
so uh on the one hand we have tights in
approximability results
and on the other hand we have tight
running time lower bounds
so our first inapproximability result
is that we show that there's no
polynomial time algorithm
which gives a better than k
approximation factor
for the densest k subgraph problem and
it's easy to see that this is type
because to get a
factor k approximation algorithm i can
just output a single vertex
and then using a bunch of known
reductions in the literature we get
titan approximability results for
several other problems including
smallest k edge subgraph
uh steiner k forest directed cyto
network
and densest case subhyper graph
okay so on the other side we also get
typed running time lower bounds
so here we're able to show that there's
no end to the little k
time algorithm that gets a constant
approximation for density k
graph and here it's also easy to see
that it's type because if you're looking
for a sub graph for size k
you can do brute force search over size
k subgraphs and enter the k
time okay so
this then yields
again using pretty simple reductions we
can get
tight running time lower bounds for the
pattern detection problem so
in pattern detection there's there's two
versions of the problem there's um where
you're looking for
an induced graph or a non-induced graph
so we can get
that there's no end to the little okay
time algorithm for any
uh k vertex induced pattern detection
problem
and uh no end to the order k
time algorithm for almost every uh
k vertex non-induced pattern detection
question so uh these these are
the sort of uh first types running time
lower bounds for
all of these problems albeit we start
with a uh the strongest planetary
hypothesis which is a stronger
hypothesis than has been used
uh before oh and i should mention that
all these results also hold for
fixed parameter tractable algorithms as
well
okay so i have two minutes left so i'll
do my best to give you a taste of the
of the proof but i might just cut to the
end in order to spare you and you can
watch uh pastan's nice
25 minute version for more details um
so both of these both of
main these about densest k subgraph are
proven by using the same reduction
and just plugging in different
parameters
so here i don't want you to take
anything away from the slide except for
that we're using the same reduction
there's going to be some parameters k l
and n which will become clear on the
next slide and we just choose different
values of
l to get the two different theorems
okay so our reduction is going to
exploit the randomized graph product
which is uh been used many times before
in
in hardness approximation reductions the
randomized graph product is defined as
follows we start with some graph
this is going to be the graph which is
our planted clique instance
and then we choose parameters k l and n
and what we do is we're going to pick uh
random subsets
capital n random subsets each of size l
vertices
uh and g and we're going to make one
vertex in
g prime for each subset of set and then
we'll add an edge between the vertices
corresponding to those subsets and g
prime if the union of those vertex sets
is a clique in the original graph so
here for example i may have chosen
x1 to be v2 v3 s2 to bv1 v2
s3 v3 v5 and then i can look and i can
see
that the union of s1 and s2
in the original graph is not a clique so
i don't put an edge there
uh the union of s1 and s3 is a clean so
i do put an edge there etc um
okay uh so i'm at the eight minute mark
but um the complete distance arguments
are
both quite simple though they do require
some uh non-obvious
um you know analysis and uh
basically we use the fact that the
random choices of the subsets uh
form a disperser in the uh original
graph all right that's it so
uh so quickly concluding so we proposed
this strongish planted click hypothesis
and we're able to get tight and
approximability results for
for several problems uh tight running
time lower bounds for several problems
future research directions uh
it would be really nice to get in
approximability results where
uh this the k depends on n so we can't
get this with our techniques
um are there more applications of this
strongish bunch of click hypothesis
uh can we prove the same
tight hardness results under different
assumptions thanks
thank you okay great um
so i have a bunch of questions but i can
also save them for later uh
anyone who wants to ask a question feel
free to
unmute yourself
yeah so so one
question is you know the reduction is is
randomized right so this is
uh you need to sort of base your
assumption on no randomized algorithm
for
for planting okay right so is there any
hope to do it uh
with deterministic algorithms or the
equivalent
conductors um it may
be possible to use some pseudorandomness
uh instead because the property that we
use
is uh that the sets will kind of form a
disperser
um but i i guess not we didn't think
about it so
i'm not sure okay
right uh so i guess
um let's think see it again
and uh next we have omri
yep i share my screen now
okay good seems to work right
okay so marie would um tell us about
limits of
order graphs and their applications
thank you
this is joint work with allah official
amit levi and yuichi yoshida
so in this talk i will discuss limits of
graph sequences
this is an analytic perspective on graph
theory where we employ
analytical terminology and tools to
study very large graphs
and this has various motivations and
applications for example
in proper testing and extreme
combinatorics there are many results
that are much more natural and easier to
prove using graph limits
and i will mention some examples as
another example in
probability or statistics limits of
graphs are useful in nonparametric model
to represent natural distributions over
large graphs
for example of social networks or
interaction graphs in
statistical physics typically one is
interested in sequences of
larger and larger graphs that have some
common characteristics
and the limit object the graph font
represent these characteristics in a
unified way
since the graphic material was
established about
15 years ago various types of limits for
commentary structures have been
developed
here are just a few representative works
and
in our work we develop a limit theory
for ordered graphs
so we consider graphs whose vertices
have an underlying ordering for example
you can think of an
image as a as an ordered as an ordered
bipartite graph
where one part corresponds to the rows
of
the rows in the image the other part
corresponds to the columns
and the edge color between row i
and column j so it's a color it's an
edge colored graph
and the the edge color between row i and
column j
corresponds to the pixel color in in the
location
i j um other examples of
naturally ordered graphs include the
temporal graphs wherever this is ordered
by time
and geometric or location based graphs
where
vertices are loaded by location
a sequence of unordered graphs is
considered convergent
if the density of any finite
substructure
a convergence among graphs in the
sequence
for example a sequence of error
reduction random graphs gn1 half
converges with probability 1 because the
subgraph
densities converge with probability one
an equivalent and more useful notion of
convergence
is via the cut distance for grass which
is uh defined here on
the right and the space of uh graphones
has many desirable properties
it is complete it is also even a compact
um graphones allow sampling and
the subgraph densities are the limiting
densities of the corresponding
graph sequence and like unordered graphs
their presentation is symmetric so it is
invariant under
measure preserving transformations which
is the same as saying for graphs that
the representation is invariant under a
running permutation over the vertices
okay so one first may ask whether we can
use
the cut distance that we used for
unordered graphs whether we can use it
to define convergence for other graphs
and the the answer turns out negative
both
when we allow measure preserving
transformations like in unordered graphs
and also when we do not allow them in
hope to preserve the ordering of the
vertices
uh so so there are some counter examples
here i explained them in more detail in
the
in the longer talk
uh but but our first contribution in in
this work is to develop
a new variant of the cut distance
which we call the cut shift distance
which correctly captures
convergence of ordered subgroup
densities
the the distance function allows making
measure preserving transformations
but we have to pay for them if if you
want to change the order of the vertices
so it allows us some flexibility
uh that that we need for the distance
function to be expressive enough
uh but we don't but we don't allow too
much expressivity
and so so so the ordering of the
vertices will
will will still make sense in the limit
object
however a graph on so so we could try
uh you to use graph fonts with with the
cut shift distance
um but the graphene is uh not a
sufficiently
expressive limit object even even if we
couple it with the the kachif distance
so so not only that we need a new
distance notion we also need some
more expressive limit object
and the limit object we device is called
an order one it is
four dimensional rather than
two-dimensional as is the case for
graphones
and this is because we need to represent
each vertex by two coordinates
one that describes its location in the
linear ordering
and another one that provides some some
sense of expressivity and finally order
ones with the cut shift distance
are sufficient to develop a limit theory
for ordered graphs
so and we proved several results that
constitute this kind of limit theory
uh these are a completeness and a
compactness theorems
that show that the space of order once
satisfies these properties
uh a sampling theorem that characterizes
how
finite order graphs can be
probabilistically generated from other
ones
and also a theorem that shows that the
finite order graphs are dense in the
space of orderance
perhaps the most interesting main result
is a pixelization lemma which
roughly states that any order one is
closed in l1 or
if you prefer humming distance to a
finite description order one
that additionally does not contain any
like noisy features that did not appear
in the original order on and this is
kind of a
useful analytic form of summary
regularity for the graphs
we give two applications to demonstrate
the usefulness for a limit object
one is a new proof of the ordered graph
removal element
the proof is much simpler than the
non-combinatorial proof that we
previously had and exempt and it
exemplifies why
uh the analytic perspective is sometimes
the most natural one
and the easiest to use one uh the other
result is a new result in extreme
combinatorics
it shows that the asymptotically the
furthest away graph
from so for any hereditary property of
ordered graphs
there is some ordered stochastic block
model
so that's generating graphs according
this
according to this stochastic block model
uh we
will uh we'll make we will generate
graphs that are
almost the furthest away from uh from
the property
and this is a generalization of a
beautiful result by a
london which also i think the proof was
was using uh graph limits
and for some future directions um
so we mostly investigated this limit
object
in a combinatorial context the
applications that we
provide this are combinatorial and it
it would be interesting to um to
understand to study autoruns as a
generic
as a generative probabilistic model for
order graphs
and obviously it will also be
interesting to
so so our limit object is is for dense
order graphs and
it would be interesting to understand
limit objects for other or the the
um graphs for example
limits that are for sparse graphs or
or image limits that are more natural i
mean our limits are not
are not really not natural for images
okay thank you
thank you um
okay great so um maybe we should uh
transition to to the next speaker and
meanwhile
feel free to to ask questions and
so next we have a vinayak
so um you know
um i'm i'm curious how did the
you decided to go from this 2d graphone
model to this 4d i mean what what
uh why was it the natural choice so
uh it just seems that the 2d is not
enough i mean we
we've seen some concrete
concrete measure theoretical reasons why
graphons are just not expressive enough
so
there was this example of
the odd click example that you might
have seen on one of the slides
so this is an example of of uh of a
sequence of other graphs that
those need they do seem to they they
need to convert i mean the the
the subconscious density is converge but
but uh
they don't seem to be to have any
reasonable uh
limit object as a graph on and and this
could be
actually proved it just seems that you
need more explosivity so we know we need
we use another coordinator for this
expressivity
and in fact uh there was an independent
work
on um on a latin squares
generalizations of permutations and this
is also a
to the object and they also seem to use
a four-dimensional limit object so
i don't have any concrete
bound showing that it's not
two-dimensional because we need to
define what two-dimensional
is but it seems to not be
two-dimensional okay
thank you um okay i guess
uh we're short on time so let's uh
go on to the the next talk um
so this is about the pseudo binomiality
of the sticky
random walk um and
presenting the the work would be
vinayakumar
all right yeah um i'm vanayk and today
i'll be presenting joint work with
venkat guruswamy and i'll be talking
about the
pseudo-binomiality of the sticky random
walk
all right so um our project is basically
considering
uh statistical properties of
the expander random walk so let me first
describe an expander
it's an expander uh expanders are
deregular graphs where you
think of the degree as like small in
terms of the number of vertices
and um it's defined based off of its
normalized adjacency matrix
so if all of its non-trivial eigenvalues
is
bounded in magnitude by some constant
less than one
we call it a spectral expander
and random walks on expanders
are very useful in pseudorandomness
they're
used a lot in constructing pseudorandom
objects
like generators extractors air
correcting codes
or amplification protocols and so
a natural question to ask is what
pseudorandom
statistical properties uh does
expand do expander walks have and this
is a
question that we surprisingly know
little about and so we hope to answer
this
so um a particular model of ex
of an expander walk we look at is one
where we have an expander graph and then
we
mark half of its vertices and uh
we look at a bit string distribution
where uh we do a random walk and then we
look at
the string the indicator string which
indicates
which step was on a marked note so for
example if we have
a random walk here you can verify that
this is the
uh bit string corresponding to it since
like the first step is not marked
the second and third steps are marked
and so on
and what we focus on is the total number
of visits to a marked node
which is equivalent to looking at the
number of ones in the string or the
hamming weight of the string
so um there has been some results
on this number for example uh using
churn off arguments
it's been shown that the number of
visits is concentrated about
n over two and uh more recently uh it's
been shown the parity bias of this
number
is exponentially small so it's like odd
and even with almost the same
probability and
this led to a breakthrough construction
of
uh epsilon balanced codes so um in
general what we what we're trying to do
is we're looking at the pseudo
binomiality
of this number and it basically how
close is this distribution
to uh the binomial distribution and we
chose the binomial distribution because
it's
the distribution of the hamming weight
of a string
and as a modest step in this direction
we uh
analyze what we call the sticky random
walk which
is a necessary proxy towards
understanding the general expander walk
so the sticky random walk uh is the fun
we take we have two parameters
n is the number of steps and lambda you
can think of as the stickiness factor
which is which will serve as the proxy
for
the expanders second largest eigenvalue
and the distribution is defined
where uh the first bit is zero or one
with equal probability
and then every subsequent bit will stick
to the current bit with probability one
plus lambda over two
and then we'll swap to the other bit
with probability one minus
lambda over two so um it can be
uh it can be shown that the sticky walk
is necessary to understanding the
expander rock because
um it basically
it represents a specific class of
expander walks with uh second largest
eigenvalue lambda
and half of its vertices marked so this
is basically a special case
of the general expander walk so
uh a main result we proved is a total
variation distance
bound so um let s be a
sticky random walk bit string and then
let t be a
purely random string uh we show that the
total variation dis tonal variation
distance between
the distribution of these hamming
weights is uh theta of lambda
and so uh of course dvd is bounded by
one
it's interesting to see as lambda goes
to zero uh
like we see the exact like dk and
the tightness of this bound we show is
realized by the event where
we uh we shift everything to the plus or
minus one
version of the walk and uh the event
that the hamming weight is at most
the square root of the number of steps
gives our
omega of lambda separation so in order
to prove the
uh upper bound what we use is uh some
fourier analysis over the kraut chick
functions
and we choose the crowd check functions
because
their inner product is uh defined based
off of
the binomial expectation and so it turns
out this is very useful in
analyzing how close this distribution is
to the binomial distribution
so if you work with it you sort of see
that the zeroth coefficient
represents how binomial it is and then
uh the remaining coefficients uh
basically show
how much it deviates from it so in
spirit
uh we're basically uh need to
sufficiently upper bound
these remaining coefficients which uh
turns out to be this expression
and doing bounding this uh by o of
lambda is essentially
how we go about this and there's some
exciting recent work
uh by cohen perry and tashma
uh just like the end of last uh 2020
where
they show a tvd bound of uh
of a lambda times some polylog factor uh
between the hamming weight of uh the
general
expander walk and the hamming weight of
a purely random string
and their approach is quite similar but
they had to
be more careful in like computing the
expectation of the crouch hook function
of
the expander indicator bit string rather
than just a
sticky bit string and as an example of
like
how much we don't know about this uh
this uh ham like of this sticky walk um
we have two results right so we have uh
one result
from churnoff saying like from chernoff
bounds saying
the uh x that the uh number of visits
is very close to the mean and we have
another saying
uh the parody is very uh the parody bias
is very small
so um what if we asked oh what's the
probability like
what's the probability the
the number of visits is at least n over
two and it's even
or like what if it's less than ever to
or odd
so even these events uh they're unknown
and so as a modest step towards
answering these questions
we look at this question in the sticky
walk
setting and so as another result
um we show that the majority and parity
bit
are almost uncorrelated by showing like
in all of these four
cases the probability is one-fourth plus
some
little o of one factor and the
the proof idea it it does depend quite a
bit on symmetry
uh and in the cases where like the
middle case where the symmetry
doesn't handle we use crowd trig
functions
in order to upper bound this central
probability coefficient
to be your little o of one factor
so some future directions would be um
we we almost have it but um can we
establish
uh of lambda factor uh for the general
expander x setting so basically can we
remove that
polylog factor um from
the distance and then uh as i said
we did depend on the symmetry of the
sticky walk
in order to show the parody majority
results so is there a way to
replace this symmetry uh
part with uh some foray analysis so that
we could perhaps generalize it
to the expander walk setting and then
finally um
is there a way to essentially reduce
more cases
more events from uh the expander walk to
the sticky walk so there are
moment generating function results that
uh
say that you can uh like
you you can reduce like you can lift uh
bounds on monotone functions from a
biased version of the sticky walk
to the general expander walk
but uh how about like non-monotone
functions like parody
is there some way we can show some
relationship between
the expander walk and the sticky walk
and so yeah
thank you for listening and that's what
i have
thank you since we're short on time
let's move on to the next speaker and
keep the question for uh for later
after the last uh talk okay so
next uh we have door i believe
yes that's true i stopped here in mark
so i was uncertain a bit but
yeah yeah so can you you can hear me
right
yeah we can see your uh slides as well
good but very good okay yeah yeah so
dorminter would just on reach two to one
games
uh thank you very shari so hi everybody
thank you for
sticking to the end of this session so
i'm going to talk about
this 201 games but before i do that let
me give you some
background of what we're talking about
so this is joint work with mark weberman
and swashkot
so it all starts of course with the pcb
filling
and to formulate it let me define the
level cover problem
so here is a formalization but basically
what is a level cover
you have a bunch of constraints which
are described by bipartite graph
you're supposed to give labels to each
one of the vertices and
you want to satisfy the constraints that
our ideas
simple enough and the goal of course is
to satisfy as many of the constraints as
possible so in this language
you can state the pcb theorem as follows
and there exists some delta less than
one
and k which is the alphabet the bound on
alphabet sizes
such that if i give you a label cover
instance it's npr out for you to tell me
whether you can satisfy all of the
constraints
or at most dealt of them
okay so this is the most vanilla basic
pcb feeling
and it's very nice you can do a bunch of
stuff with it
but often it's too weak to derive like
optimally in approximately results so
sometimes any you know maybe the result
at all
so people look for stronger versions of
this theorem
and there are sort of two main avenues
for that
so first of all you can ask to improve
sounds you can ask to reduce this data
and this is something that i'm not going
to talk about at all this is
if you are the name of repetition
theorem this is
what this is all about and it's very
good it's very useful but
not for this talk this talk is more
about
the second point which is obtaining
more strict structure on the constraints
of the problem
so this is the stock okay
so we want a better structure for the
constraints
so what is the best structure you can
hope for
what is the ultimate structure well this
is what we call
unique games
so what is a uni game it's a specific
instance
of label cover wherein the two alphabet
sizes are the same
and each constraint is as simple as it
gets
it's a one-to-one map
okay so for example maybe the alphabet
is a field and
the constraints are equations linear
equations in two variables
so uh so this is a what unique games and
a conjecture by subascot is that level
cover
remains hard on unique games more
precisely the
for all that zero for large enough
alphabet it's empire to tell whether a
given unique game is almost satisfyable
or at most delta satisfactory
so this is the conjunction and of course
because it is a conjunction
there are pros and cons of it so the
point is that
if you're willing to assume that you get
a bunch of results you get many
implications but of course the coin is
this is a conjecture
so whatever we based on it may collapse
if the conduction fails
uh good so uh so let's try maybe
something a bit weaker
let's say a new volume structure
so what is what number comes after one
two so instead of unit games we talk
about two to one games
it's basically the same except that now
each constraint is a two to one map
and not a one-to-one map
in the same paper subascot conjecture
that this problem is also held
basically the same hardness as of unique
games
and but now comes a a bit of a
difference so
now basically we know that this
conjecture is two we know that uh
this is np hard we know that two to one
games
is npr so this is a form right this is
not a conjecture it's provable
and but what is the con well less
applications
right you have to pay for something
and and the main question that we
consider in this work is are there any
intermediate problems between
two to one games and uni games
okay so for that i'm going to define
it is going to be a bit more technical
but i'm going to define basically
a new parameter of label cover problems
and this is what will determine our
intermediate problems
so let's fix it to do one game style
and now i'm going to define the richness
parameter
so for that first i'm going to associate
a partition of the alphabet
for each vertex and is an enable of it
so let's fix the vertex u on the side
with the larger alphabet
on l and now let's consider each
neighbor v of view
i claim that the name of your view
naturally induces a partition
of the alphabet of you
so why is that for each symbol that
they may get there are two symbols that
you may get
so that that is satisfy them
so this inverse map defines to you a
partition of sigma l
to set sub size to
and this is what what is written here
this is the partition that u and v
define
good so now that we define that we can
associate with each vertex
a distribution of the partitions
so for each vertex you you sample
enable the uniformity random and you
output the partition that you
redefine and intuitively
the richness parameter measures how
random looking
this partition looks like
so let's be a bit more formal but i
don't don't take it too
seriously you can look at the version
longer version of the talk
if you want to get more serious but
basically the more random looking this
tradition is the greater the richness is
and roughly speaking example this enable
v you look at other samples of pairs
if they look random then you call it
otherwise rich
and the larger area is the happier we
are
and if r is the whole thing if
everything looks completely random then
we call it
we call the game fully reach our just
which will
drop the fully
what's so so now this is sort of the the
main definition that we have
in this work and this
property raises several questions
what can you say about these problems
and how do they relate
to unique games and two-to-one games
so let me state the two conjectures that
we make in this paper
so the first conjecture asserts that if
they give you
a fully reached one game it's npl to
tell
whether it's almost fully satisfiable or
at most absence in this weapon
but note that here unlike unique games
there is no reason to believe that
satisfiable instances are easy
so this is our second conjecture we
conjecture that
even on satisfactorily instances it's
still npr to tell whether it's
satisfiable or
it was the epsilon city slab
so this is these are the two conjectures
that we make and
uh to the natural questions is
how these conjectures related to unique
games
and secondly why study them of course
and
so the main sort of result that we prove
in this paper is that
the first conjecture is actually
equivalent
to uni games it's completely equivalent
to ubc
and one direction is easy if you assume
uni games it's very easy to ship to
to reduce it to reach to one games
that other direction is more tricky and
this is
where most of our effort goes i i should
mention that
the reduction itself is standard it's a
reduction from
a paper by kindergarten and
but actually to do the assignments we
have to use some new analytical tools
and in particular some hyper-contractive
inequality on the symmetry group
good but now that we know that
conjecture one is equivalent to
dc it raises the question of what about
conjecture two
because clearly conjecture two is
stronger than conjecture one so
what can you say about it and what i
sort of
want to argue is that this is sort of a
version of unique games with perfect
completeness
but one that is plausibly hard
and i find it very interesting and
like in the next slide i'm going to
basically tell you what what i think
about it
but this is sort of the main message
that
that our war gives that there is this
ladder of problems
that we want to study that eventually
will
lead us maybe to uni games but there is
even a stronger conjecture that
may have greater implications
yes so this is a sort of the last slide
of my talk so
so this is uh what i said so
here is here are some open directions
so uh it's easy to show that
if you assume the average conjecture for
equals one
actually it's not an assumption because
it is true for q equals one
you get that you need games between half
and epsilon now is empty harder
and if you assume full richness then our
main result says that you get the whole
thing
so an interesting question is what what
would you get if you
prove that fall which games are empty
harder
would you get something better than half
so
my feeling is that answer should be yes
but we don't know
and secondly this is sort of the the
point that i tried to deliver on the
last slide
now that we have some conjecture that is
stronger than ugc
and it's plausible and as perfect
completeness
we can hope to use it to prove harmless
force that is fairly instances
so there is a very nice result by
vagavendra that uses
udc in order to prove some dichotomy for
the entire class of csps but because of
this
imperfect completeness it doesn't apply
for satisfaction
so i have some hope that we may be able
to cover analogs of
this result but yeah this is a long road
and
so far we only have some preliminary
results in a
work in progress and
finally this is sort of a more moral
question but
uh there is this object called the
glassman graph which
is used to prove a hardness of
standalone to one
which as i said is the same as average
for equals one
can we find some combinatorial gadget
that will hopefully give us so
possibly give us harness for other games
so i think that even coming up with some
candidates would be very interesting
and but so far we don't know of
anything that is too promising and so
that's
all i have thank you for listening thank
you
okay so i think
[Music]
we are now uh uh
we should start the discussion now and i
i invite you all to
to ask questions and open with the flow
uh
to ask question for any of the five
speakers for giving us
these great talks um
um
jay go ahead sorry sorry i i had a
question for the
pseudo binomiality you talk uh is there
a
is there any aspect in which we
know that the expander walk differs from
the sticky walk
or as far as we know they behave very
similarly in terms of any
anything i might want to do
uh like what do you mean differ i get
like
uh like there are some like
the sticky walk uh can be simulated by
like
some some like expander walks like
like the set like the sticky walk over
like lambda will like simulate like
only a certain um only like
certain expanders but um
it's it's not known for like arbitrary
expanders like
what really the relationship is with
like
we we know like moment generating
function like
upper bounds uh with well and even in
that case it's
uh it's upper bounded by a slightly more
general
version of the sticky walk like a biased
version
so um it's it's there's no like it
i think it's more like folklore that
like oh
uh if i have a marked expander i can
sort of think of it
as a sticky walk type of thing but
there aren't many concrete results that
bridge the two together
thanks
thank you uh i had a question for about
the ordered graphics talk
i think to omri um i was wondering uh
if you could tell a little bit more
about why the cut distance why you have
to use this like cut shift distance
rather than the cut distance
yeah um so the cut distance usually
um so so there is the cut norm
um that where you can compare two graphs
but you don't allow reordering of the
vertices
and so this the cut norm if you don't
allow uh
reordering there are some examples that
where it is just
not not expressive enough so basically
you want sub graph density so you want
that if
a sequence of ordered graphs is
convergent in terms of
subgroup densities then
it will also be convergent in in the
distance
norm that we use um but in in the cut
norm
and this this example doesn't converge
um so so it just seems that uh
if you allowed a little bit of
flexibility than this example so
this example is we call it the the odd
click example so
um you take a a graph on n vertices
where an order graph of any vertices
where all the odd vertices are connected
to each other and that's it
no no other edges so it seems that if
you can slightly reorder the vertices
then they become
they become the same and the cut norm
between them will be
become zero but if you do not allow
reordering the cut norm is
is very large on the other hand if you
allow um
if you allow transformations if you
allow permutations over over the
ordering
then you just you just lose the order
so you need some you need some
flexibility but not too much
so and and this is what we provide
okay that makes sense thank you
yes um
add another question yeah go ahead uh no
go ahead
oh um okay sure um
i was wondering um i know there's work
on like i think they're called adrian
farst random walks
on graphs um which i think you did
deoconus and collaborators
um and i i was wondering if like and
this
i know this is like a little bit nice so
maybe but i was wondering like is there
any potential link between like like the
sticky walk
and like edgy and first box because
there it's like once you've seen an edge
you want to go to it more
um whereas here it's like you want to
stand over ticks you're on i realize
these feel pretty different but like
is there any chance of like if it gets
through there is there any chance of the
techniques
might cross a fire or anything um i
actually haven't like
thought of like edge reinforced graphs
so
it seems that they might be similar i'm
not sure though
uh i'd have to think about that okay
sorry
it's interesting
i guess i have maybe more of a soft
question for
all the um
speakers today uh you know this uh
the topic of this uh session was
analytical tools uh so in all innovative
talks you you describe
very interesting open questions and you
know sophisticate analytical tools that
you used
uh either to solve that or to make some
progress on it
and maybe you know something kind of
an intriguing and uh is how do you find
the right tool for for for like the the
questions that you
that you're uh working on and
and maybe another ano vice versa you can
ask how do you find the right question
for your given tool right if you have a
very good tool and you know
i have to use this tool to do something
interesting so if you can
share your thoughts about that
okay so i i will say something about it
um
[Music]
so the the original proofs for the
kcl type theorems that i mentioned use
the hyper-contractive inequality
and actually we try to get rid of it
because it's it have some limitations uh
use the the corollary that we use there
use the degree of the function maximum
degree and
and when we take a boolean function and
cut we can translate it at some degree
and
then we might uh learn something about
it without even
conductivity but we lose the booleanity
and sometimes even the
uh the bounded values of the function
so we try and there are other words that
did
some proofs for this uh theorems
that doesn't use the hypercontractivity
but the tool that we use the
logs of inquiry is very close to the
hyper-contractivity
it's even considered as the
um the limit the the limit version of it
when you
took some parameter there um
and then we
actually in much effort we did is to
analyze
the general version of the of the logs
of
inequality and there used some uh
tools that we actually use in other
works and
uh and they're pretty common in in this
uh
area so it was
um some combination of some trivial
tools to use and
uh and some others that
are more original for me i'm always
fascinated by how much
we are we can get by just a simple tool
of random restriction that
you know year after year we see more
results using this simple tool
perhaps interfere and just make
like one small remark so there is a
jumbo game of course and if you look at
these papers in the
analysis of boolean functions it's it's
hard to see
but they all boil down to random
stations
like he does them very very cleverly and
sometimes you know
under the wooden but uh but yeah
it's a very powerful technician like
once you know how to use it
and combine it with other things the
sky's the limit
um don't if you have like particular
recommendations for like
particularly beautiful examples of
random restrictions in the use of
analysis bullying functions uh i'm sure
i should start with
the current paper of course but uh any
other cool applications of random
restrictions in this area
um well like the the famous examples are
right
the switching them uh and
you know applications for it improve
complexity
and so a good a good survey
by paul there's a very beautiful server
by paul beam if you
want to learn a little bit more about
that and
probably door would say more stuff or
others
feel free yeah yeah it's freaky
so uh
yes so there are some early applications
of it for like the problem of hunter
testing
which are you know not too complicated
but
still quite clever but after that it
sometimes get a bit
a bit out like uh so you can try to
prove that instead of
uh hunter theory i'm saying that if your
fourier tale is
decaying quickly then your function is a
hunter is close to junta
so if you do if you don't care too much
about getting optimal parameters
it's a very nice exercise and it's a
it's a paper to do it with no
restrictions but
if you want to get the optimal thing
then you have to be vulgar
[Music]
yeah i get so i have another soft
question maybe
i'll focus it more more now on like it's
maybe relevant to this little
door no marie but but you know feel free
to to answer as well
so it seems that you know some of you
develop like a new definition or a new
conjecture
uh when doing it how like how do you
know this is the right one how do you
like you know you have so many choices
when you make a new definition
of so what made you choose this
definition or this conjecture
versus any other choice
so for us we we saw what didn't work and
we
we guessed so so there the analytic
results that we developed we
kind of developed some of them already
from a combinatorial perspective
so we had some guesses um what should
work and what shouldn't
and i mean surprisingly things work i'm
not true
i'm not sure why uh relatively early
guesses over the world but
we just tried several
uh several types of definitions and
constructions
and they didn't work and then one of
them did
um yes it's a matter of trial of trial
and error i guess
right and also like in your talk you
sort of talk about these
failed attempts that sort of lead you to
the next one so that's that's a good
approach yeah
and maybe still yeah i guess in our case
with the
strongest uh plenty click hypothesis the
choice of the conjecture was pretty i
mean if the hypothesis is uh
kind of uh suggested by the current you
know frontier
of algorithms when we started the work
we were trying to
get reductions between different
distributional problems so we wanted to
look at
like whether we could get a reduction
from plant and clique to
a average case version of densest
k-subgraph
and there like we were willing to be
more flexible about
you know kind of how like the running
time of one of them uh
translates the running time of the other
so we we weren't married to you know
like uh
and to the little log in but but we
thought like whatever
correspondence we could get was
interesting but then we realized that
this very simple reduction
if you start with the strongest
planetary capacitors gives uh tight and
approximability results for um
dense case of ref so we were happy with
that
you see so it's so so the the order is
not necessarily the order
which we presented more or less maybe
you have the reduction person than the
conjecture later
yeah and also like
another question that i i saved from
earlier about your talk is
uh i mean i'm not super uh familiar with
everything in this
area but i know that there are some
reductions on like
um you know hardest of approximation of
cadence subgraph from
ceph right uh so the question is you
know what's
like how would you compare the two
results like in terms of regimes of
parameters and in terms of you know
you know this one implies the other or
okay so here i'm a little bit worried
that i'll say something incorrect
but i can tell you my uh what i
recall so so the results that start from
seth they managed to get an
approximability where this uh term
k can be almost polynomial in n
so uh uh right and we don't get to take
our k that large so rk is our
um it's most uh poly logarithmic
um right so that's the main uh kind of
uh
difference and and there's i mean
there's a number of different there's
there's a different densest case of
graph
you know almost the same reduction but
they don't do a randomized reduction
they
they take kind of all of the sets and
then they're able to get
hardness for a different region of
dance's case subgraph so
yeah so sort of like the choices that
you make in the reduction really
uh or in the starting problem really
determine kind of which regime you can
handle
yeah thanks
uh hi uh uh i had a kind of a uh
discussion uh uh uh
for the panel so i was um thinking
if uh uh these excellent on
results can be extended or
uh scaled by on using some sort of a
function approximation uh
for a multi-layered or a
hierarchical uh graphical
um structure so how will that work
um maybe uh in a form of
multi-layered
neural networks such that these
results can be well-bounded on some sort
of a
approximation problems with respect to
large data
sets so i was thinking more in terms of
um
machine learning here
can you maybe focus your question uh for
which uh
speaker are you referring it or is it
just a general
it's just a discussion query for uh
for all the five uh uh
speakers so if um
i was thinking what were their thoughts
with respect to
the uh scalability and throwing in some
approximations for um making this their
results uh how do i say it
uh extend to multiple
domains or uh uh specifically uh
easily uh generalized
so
i i hope i am clear
yeah i i i'm not sure that that i
understood exactly if you can give an
example
for for maybe is
related to one of them yeah uh with with
respect to suppose
uh having multi layers of the same
uh uh
approximations with respect to suppose
convergence or
a uh uh inference
so uh in both the con context can these
hand crafted
[Music]
how do i say uh hard um
bounded problems can be scaled with
respect to
uh having large data sets and can be uh
easily uh generalized so that's what
i was thinking from a general
um machine learning perspective
okay i i didn't understand your question
because i'm not uh
exploiting machine learning but maybe i
have some answer for you
um our work you actually can extend it
to
uh bounded functions
so maybe if this type of extension
interests you
um this is actually what we prove
because we need it for some uh for our
main force but
maybe that
i got that but i was yeah
thinking with respect to the exchange
okay okay uh so
suppose if i put it naively uh
if i i want to have a
sub graph here which can solve those
queries uh or those those problems in a
more
efficient manner i have some sort of a
causal
relationship with respect to a
hierarchical uh graphical structure so
i was thinking more in terms of that
making those uh uh
small l algorithms uh
combined together to solve a bigger
problem
uh more in the case of machine learning
or
if you take this or extend this
into a reinforcement learning
context so i was thinking more in terms
of that
okay then fine i think you are uh
a way ahead of us i mean we i mean you
see connections that
we are still there
but you know some of these questions are
uh
relevant to not a very big question like
you know
b versus np and stuff like that so
that's definitely
yeah okay uh any more questions
a quick question for for sd
um do your techniques give you bergens
hunter theorem or is there any hope of
getting
bergen's hunter theorem
what do you ask oh um like you use
random restrictions and log sub 11
equality to get kkl freed good and talaq
ran right
and like another hunter theorem is is
burgundy
yeah is there any hope to sort of use
your techniques to get
bergen's theorem yes actually i'm not
sure
it's it's not already done okay
exactly this is the uh
the purpose of of this talk to find more
uh more applications to this technique
okay cool yeah
thanks you're welcome
right thank you thank you for sticking
around i guess
we are now well into our lunch break so
i'll let you
take take a break and maybe eat dinner
or lunch depending on which continent
you
are and uh
see you later thank you